the scientist who's disproven doomsday
model destroyed the global economy has
resigned from his position after it came
out that he broke his own lock down
order to sleep with his married mistress
all of which brings up one question why
should we be expected to listen to
scientists when the scientists don't
even listen to themselves Chris Cuomo
goes on an unhinged rant a salon owner
in Texas tells a power-hungry judge to
pound sand and president Trump vows
revenge on China all that more I'm
Michael Knowles and this is the Michael
Nolt show
[Music]
oh the scientists how they reveal
themselves sometimes metaphorically
sometimes literally apparently - they're
married mistresses all of this as
governors around the country or urging
more caution more heed more fear even as
some of the states are reopening we'll
see the effects of some of that in a
little bit even as they're saying that
they're saying you have to follow the
rules you have to do exactly what we say
the governor of West Virginia came out
and used even more colorful language
than that again I encourage all
businesses that are allowed to open to
do so only if they follow the guidelines
to keep West Virginia safe I don't know
that we actually even had to bleep that
because at first I couldn't tell look
West Virginia it's pretty serious place
you know that's a pretty direct tell you
like I see it you know kind of American
state I think what he was actually
trying to say was on his sheet of paper
it said if you follow the guidelines but
then he saw the word can so as if you
fought can follow the guidelines and the
way it came out
obviously we have to bleep it if we're
gonna play it on the show but I like
that attitude we're gonna open up if you
follow the guidelines okay yes sir
unfortunately most of the people who
were urging us to do exactly what they
say are not doing it in this
tongue-in-cheek or accidental sort of
way and the chief among them the chief
offender of this is Neil Ferguson this
name it's probably isn't gonna go in the
history books because he's probably
gonna be written out of the history but
he should because this is the guy more
than anybody responsible for the global
economic shutdown this is the guy before
who came up with the infamous Imperial
College model that predicted 2.2 million
deaths or more you know in the United
States from coronavirus so Neil Ferguson
says if you guys pursue herd immunity if
you guys let the virus run rampant you
shut down your businesses then you're
gonna have millions and millions of
death on your hands you've got to stay
in your apartment okay fine all the
governments of the world including the
UK where he lives
shut down then turns out Neil Ferguson
didn't follow his own lockdown order why
am I surprised
Neil Ferguson on at least two separate
occasions this is a 51 year old
scientist broke the lockdown order so
that his 38 year old married lover could
leave her home travel all the way across
London and have a fun time have a little
lockdown and chill with the government
scientists this is right after Neil
Ferguson got finished self isolating for
two weeks for testing positive for
coronavirus so it wasn't even out of an
abundance of caution you know I met a
guy who met a guy who met a guy who had
coronavirus and so I'm gonna stay home
the guy was self isolating after testing
positive and yet people are breaking
these orders Neil Ferguson sort of
accepted responsibility he has resigned
from his government position it's not
enough okay
and as we're seeing more and more
scientists and the politicians who are
using the scientists being exposed for
getting getting this virus so wrong
you're gonna see the excuses pile up I
love Neil Ferguson's excuse which we'll
get to in a second but it's not just
Neil Ferguson it's other scientists its
media personalities its governors it's
everybody colluding together to try to
cover up for this a terrible damage that
they've wrought I'll get to that in a
second first I got to thank a new
sponsor you know I got to thank all of
our sponsors these days for sticking
with us in difficult times and I'm very
excited for this new sponsor rad power
bikes you know you've seen them around
if you haven't ridden them yourself
these electric bikes that are becoming
so popular they're great for getting out
especially since we've had to spend so
much time indoors whether you want a new
way to commute or to get around the city
or out in nature even with the kids in
tow you've got to try a rad
our bike rad power bike is a cross
between a traditional bike and a moped
but here's the key it doesn't require a
special driver's license like a moped
would you can go up to 20 miles per hour
without pedaling so you can get out and
about without getting sweaty they're
great for commuting they're great for
getting out on the trail hauling
groceries or transporting the kids on
your back and unlike other ebikes
they're actually affordable plus to show
appreciation for those that service rad
Power bikes is offering $100 off all
ebike purchases for active and
ex-military first responders teachers
and students do you know someone who
loves being active outdoors tell them
about rad power bikes right now they
offer flexible financing for as low 0%
APR right now is a limited time offer
get a free accessory with the purchase
of a bike that is right get a free gift
of up to $100 in value and free shipping
to the lower 48 states to get this
special offer
text the word Knowles right now to
64,000 that is Keo wles
to 64,000 kayo wles to 64,000 all right
Neil Ferguson accepts responsibility for
violating his own order he says I accept
I made an error of judgment and took the
wrong course of action I have therefore
step back from my involvement in the
government scientific advisory group for
emergencies I acted in the belief that I
was immune having tested positive for
coronavirus and completely isolated
myself for almost two weeks after
developing symptoms so you see it's not
a full apology because he's making
excuses look I thought I was fine okay
it's not actually a big deal but it's a
political issue and you pesky people
with your politics keep getting involved
in my science and so anyway I guess I'll
step down I deeply regret any
undermining of the clear messages around
the continued need for social distancing
to control this devastating epidemic the
government guidance is unequivocal and
is there to protect all of us okay then
why didn't you follow it oh if I have to
hear the phrase social distancing again
once this pandemic is over I never want
those two words to be next to each other
it's social distancing we're just we're
all repeating these phrases like we're
robots we're all mindlessly repeating
phrases the government's guidance is
unequivocal the government is there to
protect us beep boop beep boop well you
clearly
Neil Ferguson doesn't believe that
because he violated it which is fine
okay admit that you don't think the
government guidance is mandatory
necessary for everybody
admit that much of the science behind
this whole response this whole
government reaction was bunk was bogus
admit that your study was wrong okay
I'll forgive what I don't mind that some
scientific expert got things wrong I
don't mind that the government got
things wrong what I really mind is being
gas-lit about this whole thing and being
told to repeat platitudes and being told
to repeat scientific certainties that
turn out to be not so certain another
hypocrite on all of this another guy who
clearly doesn't believe what he's saying
in another sector of the economy is on
CNN Chris Cuomo brother of Andy Cuomo
governor of New York one of the most
famous politicians during the pandemic
telling people to lock down Chris Cuomo
goes on CNN now that finally people are
starting to push back a little bit
starting to open up he doubles down in a
largely incoherent rant I pulled out the
most coherent parts to try to get to his
argument but you can see increasingly
desperate telling people to stay at home
personally the lesson for me is obvious
my lesson is gratitude it's my first day
back in the office and more than a month
so many of you were so good to me both
in my family and to my family I'll just
say thank you I will spend my time in
this capacity trying to justify the
faith that so many of you have put in me
but while my own covet battle is mostly
over I'm worried that so many seem to
think it's mostly over for all of us and
that is just dead wrong facts case
numbers climbing pretty much everywhere
sixty-eight thousand plus deaths now two
weeks ago the president said we would
have 60,000 deaths period now his
administration is reportedly privately
projecting they're going to be 9/11 like
death tolls on a daily basis by early
June and yet they want to push reopening
now look no one has accused this
president of being fact focused
or even write in on any of this but you
don't need him to mislead you in fact
don't put this on Trump we are deceiving
ourselves no you're deceiving us you
Chris Cuomo specifically not even just
CNN you don't need Donald Trump to
deceive you because I Chris Cuomo will
deceive you do you remember what was a
week ago two weeks ago Chris Cuomo
pretended for a month to be isolated and
quarantined in his basement of his house
because he was diagnosed with corona
virus and then they filmed this big
segment on CNN where Chris was walking
up the stairs for the first time and he
sees his wife and his kids he said oh
this is what I've been waiting for that
I've just been waiting for this to see
my beloved family for the first time in
a month and then it turns out he had
been violating the order the whole time
because he got into an altercation on
the street outside walking with his
family with a 65 year old guy in a
bicycle who said wait a second you're
the CNN guy you said you're being
quarantined your brother is ordering all
of the quarantine what are you doing
outside and they got into an altercation
this guy was not taking the advice that
he was giving you because there's one
set of rules for the scientists there's
one set of rules for the media
personalities there's one set of rules
for political elites and then there's
another set of rules for you peasants
okay look it doesn't really matter if
Chris Cuomo stays in his basement for
four weeks who cares
like his family priority was exposed to
it anyway it's not that big a deal in
their age group so you know he can go
out but you you peasant you dirty person
you you nothing you pleb you can't go
outside because then that might threaten
public health but everyone else all the
elites get to do it because like look
they're really clean and meticulous so
just don't don't worry about that don't
pay no attention to the man behind the
curtain
I love the numbers he gives he goes this
is not over cases are rising every day
duh yeah unless the virus just
completely stops unless all time comes
to a standstill there will be more cases
tomorrow than the day before right
unless unless nobody gets in fact
that's not how viruses work but that's
not the number that we're looking at we
want to look at how first of all deaths
obviously lag infection rates but how
deaths are moving how infection rates
are moving then we can see how this
virus is going that's why even some
liberal governors are beginning to
reopen because we have no other choice
but Cuomo says no don't do it
he gets more desperate the more the rain
goes on those are the facts but there's
also feel fatigue I've had it seasons
changing it's getting warm want to get
back to it look at these fools fools I
know they want to be out there
fools it's not about you what about the
other people and look I'm not gonna
castigate you that's not my job I'm not
your daddy but we have to think about
this we are rushing to get back out of
want not just out of need all right
beautiful weather does not make for a
beautiful reality yes we're tired of bad
news yes the government is not doing
things it should be and there's no
question that this is all real but so
are the numbers the relaxing of stay
home orders doesn't mean Cove it isn't a
problem anymore in fact the opposite is
the truth I know I said that already I'm
gonna repeat a lot of things because
it's not getting through things will get
worse I don't care how you reopen okay
Chris things will get we're okay you you
bet buddy well that's why your
castigating all of those fools who were
going on outside he has the audacity to
call them fools even though he himself
did the very same thing by the way when
the pandemic was far worse when it was
raging far more than it is right now did
any of you succeed at deciphering
exactly what he was saying because I
couldn't really he he just has these
snippets of ideas and then they kind of
go away and then he he realizes he's
kind of retreading old ground but maybe
not quite as I know I'm repeating myself
but the reason he's repeating himself is
because his argument is very confused
and his argument is very confused
because he doesn't know what he's
talking about he tried to make the
argument for weeks that we all have to
lock down we all have to quarantine this
is the end of the world we're gonna have
two million people
dad and then that didn't happen and then
more evidence that that didn't happen
beyond just the numbers is Chris Cuomo
wasn't believing it himself at the time
and he went outside but still for some
reason he doesn't want anything to
reopen may be political advantage maybe
that's why some of these Democratic
politicians are so keen on keeping the
economy depressed and then he's got us
keep making that argument but he can't
keep making that argument because the
evidence is all around us the rant that
he goes on gets even weirder but I just
we can't we can't play anymore Chris
Cuomo I'm not giving him any more of my
show time but he gets more desperate and
he tries to convince people by the end
of the argument tries to convince people
that going outside isn't that great he
says at the end he goes think about look
if you if we reopen think about what
you're giving up what do you what are
you going back to what you want to you
want to go back to like restaurants and
seeing your loved ones and walking
outside in the park and on the beach and
going to work and earning a paycheck or
even wants that nobody wants that
because now you get to spend time with
family your family's gonna starve but
you get to spend time with them
that's a they've gotten so desperate
that now they're making the argument
well you want to work and go outside why
don't why not just live in your little
pod for the rest of your life and plug
Tiger King into your head and just
consume trash media including CNN until
until the end of your days that's the
argument they're made you have to go
outside this is the argument the left
has been making for years now why do you
have to fly what you have to go on
airplanes why do you have to drive why
do you have to work and travel and move
why do you have to consume products why
do you have to do any of that stuff
can't you just work and go to sleep and
not really bother anything and let me
enjoy nature when the irony of course
whether it's it's often the
environmental left making this whether
it's Leonardo DiCaprio or anyone else
it's people who fly on private jets it's
people who go on their own mega yachts
it's people like Al Gore Oh as a giant
home that that could power many many
homes if you divvied it up
the rules never apply to them and yet
they are so willing to emotionally
manipulate you to castigate you to use
Chris Cuomo's word
I mean it's usually not as blatant as
the the chief scientist the most famous
scientist in the world on this issue
saying you all have to stay at home and
meanwhile he's slipping his mistress in
through the back door it's usually not
quite as obvious as Chris Cuomo saying
we've all got to stay home because my
brother Andy Cuomo says we've got to
stay home meanwhile he's slipping out
the back door and going on jogs in South
Hampton it's usually not that obvious
but the hypocrisy is always there here's
a doctor medical doctor an expert one of
our our benevolent betters who's gonna
run our lives for us and take politics
away from self governing people this guy
Jeremy Foust
MD MS that's his twitter name he's got
to put his degrees on Twitter that's how
you know he's a very serious person yeah
I think I'm gonna start doing that I'm
gonna the Michael Noel's BA that's good
that's how you know I've got a I've got
a degree I've got a credential so he
puts this out on Twitter and he proposes
a new concept listen to this proposing a
new concept it's called your death
number your death number is the number
of deaths of your fellow Americans
you're willing to accept to save say
1,000 jobs for context we've lost around
461 jobs for every one death so far
what's your death number I don't know
who this person is obviously I haven't
followed him he's a blue check from
Harvard Medical School so it gives me
some context of his point of view what a
disgusting thing to say it's just the
same narrative we've heard from the
beginning
if you oppose shutting down the global
economy then you're killing people
you're a murderer
if you think that people should it like
ever go back to work you've got blood on
your hands you're a bad person not a
good person like the good people who
completely misled us based on bunc fake
science and locked down the global
economy and then didn't abide by the
lockdown orders themselves but forced
everyone else to all the peasants those
are the good people but the bad people
are say you a middle-class salon worker
in Texas who just wants to feed her
family we'll get to that
Dorina second that's a true story it's
not a hypothetical those are the bad
people in this bizarre world of course
it's bunk right we we know it's not a
choice between we've got to save this
job or kill this person first of all
when you destroy 30 million jobs people
die people actually die from them every
one percentage point the unemployment
rate ticks up more and more people are
dying we're gonna die from suicides and
drug overdoses and other things too so
that part is gone the other side of it
is with the lockdowns we're not sure
that that's saved even one life the
purpose of the lockdown as I've said
before is to not overwhelm health care
system and to buy time to get a vaccine
no evidence we're gonna get a vaccine
before the virus spreads through the
population and we didn't even come close
to overwhelming the health care system
anywhere including even in the epicenter
New York Javits Center was empty USNS
comfort empty so no evidence that the
lockdowns have saved lives evidence that
the shut down has killed people the
entire concept he's proposing is
ridiculous but let me propose another
concept here's this is this is an even
newer concept than this doctors my
concept is let's reject the modern
ideologies that reduce politics to
bean-counting and utilitarianism and
this debt they're not this death and
that reduce all of life to matter and
let's maybe reject those stupid modern
now we would say leftist ideologies in
favor of a fuller view of politics that
takes into account what human life
really is and what it means to live in
society just a crazy idea I know how
about I mean I maybe that's an older
concept the older concept that we we not
just export all of our politics to these
experts in lab coats who don't even
believe what they say you know the
emperor has no clothes that's what it
comes down to the scientist has no
clothes literally in the case of that
guy in the UK Neil Ferguson he very part
of his problem right now is that he
didn't have his clothes on for quite a
bit of the pandemic they have no clothes
and yet the left treats science like
it's a god Oh is listen to the
scientists I follow science
I believe in science they actually use
this kind of language well if science is
your God then science is a god that
failed God that failed is a phrase that
was used to refer to communism back in
the 20th century for all these
communists guys like Arthur Kessler
people like Whittaker Chambers who who
believed you know communism was a
replacement religion for people who had
lost their religion became atheists but
the the Utopia the perfection of
communism failed okay what it was not
infallible and that was when a lot of
people became disillusioned with that
scientism which is what we've seen
throughout this pandemic scientism the
way to outsource all of our politics all
the hard decisions the serious eternal
questions about ethics and how we live
the ability the decision to export all
of that to some guy in a lab coat
because he's he knows how to run my life
he knows how to make moral decisions for
me for some reason because he got a
degree in chemistry that scientism is a
god that failed to and we've got to stop
allowing demagogues and hack politicians
push that onto us president Trump is
showing the way here a little bit
president Trump he has been criticized
for being too tough you know he uses his
press conferences to argue with the
scientists he he's rambunctious he's
tweeting about liberating different
states he's not showing enough empathy
he's not deferring entirely to the
scientists he was asked in an interview
on ABC with David David we're how do you
pronounce his name Jerome we're I don't
know he was asked what he would say to
the families of the people who have been
killed by coronavirus and he expressed a
keen sense of empathy we've lost more
people now than we lost in the Vietnam
War
what do you want to say to those
families tonight I want to say I love
you I want to say that we're doing
everything we can I also want to say
that we're trying to protect people over
60 years old we're trying so hard I want
to just say to the people that have lost
family and have lost love and the people
that have just suffered so badly and
just made it and just made it that we
love you
we're with you we're working with you
we're supplying vast amounts of money
like never before we want that money to
get to the people and we want them to
get better and we want them you can
never really come close to replacing
when you've lost some no matter how well
we do next year I think our economy is
going to be raging it's gonna be so good
no matter how well those people can
never ever replace somebody they love
but we're gonna have something that
they're gonna be very proud of and to
the people that have lost someone there
is nobody I don't sleep at nights
thinking about it there's nobody that's
taking it harder than me but at the same
time I have to get this enemy defeated
and that's what we're doing David that's
what we're doing remember that answer
you should write that answer down you
should clip that answer out that is such
a wise distillation of the conservative
sense of politics I know people don't
consider Donald Trump to be a political
philosopher I generally don't either but
he gets it he gets it at least on that
point what do you say to the people who
have died from coronavirus what are you
gonna do or the premise of the question
is a leftist premise okay there's this
epidemic people are dying from it you're
the president what are you gonna do
you've got to stop it the leftist
premise is there's no limit to politics
we can solve any problem with politics
because politics is a science and so
when we just put the experts in charge
they'll figure out the perfect
scientific political solution and then
we won't have any more death or misery
anymore that's what you're that's what
you're supposed to say I'm the kind of
leftist progressive idea of politics and
what does Trump say he says I would tell
them I love them this is such a hard
thing I love you what
that's all we want that's all we want to
hear I love you a sense of empathy a
sense of human solidarity and a sense of
humility that politics can't fix
everything
it can't we've done everything we can
we've thrown spaghetti at the wall don't
wear masks wear masks lock down don't
lock down hydroxychloroquine some other
drug this kind of drug UV light what's
throwing everything of lockdown travel
from China lockdown travel from Europe
we've done everything and the virus is
just gonna spread and it's gonna spread
like other viruses spread like other
plagues have spread throughout all of
human history is we're not immortal
we're not invincible our brains are not
infinite and our politics can't solve
every problem don't overwhelm the
healthcare system but we didn't buy time
to get a vaccine okay we bought a lot of
time but that can't go on forever even
the whole idea was flatten the curve
right that was the the best idea they
could come up with flatten the curve
means the same number of people are
going to get it and assume you don't
overwhelm the healthcare system and you
don't have a vaccine the same number of
people are gonna die and that's a sad
fact it's a tragic fact of life the left
denies that tragic fact of life to a
degree they deny mortality I mean in
some ways they explicitly deny mortality
here these all these kind of leftist
futurists talking about how they're
gonna get the Cure and there's through
technology we're gonna live forever
right but more generally they deny the
fact that we're all we're all gonna die
someday so everything is about living in
fear and clutching your pearls and the
if if the coronavirus doesn't get us
then the Sun Monster is gonna get us and
global warming and we've all got to hide
indoors and not go outside lest heaven
forfend we die which we're all gonna do
at some point hopefully not soon we want
to minimize that risk but conservatives
accept the tragic fact of life human
nature has fallen we are mere mortals
our politics is not able to do every
single thing it's not able to do very
much at all and when we try to create a
politics that can solve every problem
very often it creates more misery
than we started with in the first place
Trump goes from that keen insight maybe
he wasn't even aware of that in some
maybe it's just his gut maybe he's not
formulating all of this in his head good
good I mean I think a key part of that
sort of conservative insight is that
your gut can lead you in a pretty
correct direction but he goes straight
from that into what we're gonna do now
facing China how we're going to move
forward in the realm that politics can
achieve things in namely in
international trade in manufacturing in
shoring up our supply chain we'll get
into that in a second then we'll get
into an important symbol the Trump
showed you know I feel the the messaging
out of the White House has been a little
little back and forth unfortunately
during this pandemic right sometimes you
think okay it's going to be really
hopeful we're gonna start pushing then
it's we've got to hunker down again then
we're gonna leave it up to the states
and we're not gonna leave it up to the
states it's just been of course it's a
pandemic so there's gonna be some
confusion but I think now the White
House is getting really on the right
track here and you see it even in a
symbol Donald Trump walking through a
manufacturing plant he's not wearing
that mask left is furious about that
we'll get to in a second then we'll get
to a great bit of resistance from a
salon owner in Texas who refuses the
Orwellian political power grab of a
judge
then I don't know if I mentioned this to
you Ruth Bader Ginsburg is in the
hospital we'll get to what that means
obviously has a lot of implications but
first I want to take a moment to tell
you about daily wires newest most
exclusive membership tear the all-access
insider the all-access insider
membership tear is our premier level of
membership all access members get the
benefits of our membership tiers all the
other ones including an ad-free website
experienced access to all of our live
broadcasts and shell library access to
the shows mail bags and the full three
hours of the Ben Shapiro show along with
dedicated editorials from Ben Shapiro
all access members also get other
amazing gifts including of course the
irreplaceable the one and only leftist
tears tumblr they also get to join live
exclusive online Q&A its daily wires new
discussion feature available on both the
website and the daily wire app they also
get to participate in all access live
our brand-new interactive programming
feature
one of us daily wire hosts as we hang
out with you each night at 8 p.m.
Eastern 5:00 p.m. Pacific I'll be
joining you tomorrow and and Ben Shapiro
will be hosting this Friday so head on
over to daily wire comm slash subscribe
to join daly waters all-access Club with
a new membership or an upgrade and get
10% off with coupon code Knowles that's
daily wire.com slash subscribe see you
there we'll be right back with a lot
more
so Trump says I love you obviously
there's no amount of technological
utilitarian leftist calculation that can
ever replace one person who's died in
your family that's the right attitude
very conservative attitude very correct
then he moves on to what politics can
accomplish which is in all these other
political realms namely in manufacturing
he makes the announcement that the u.s.
is taking back our manufacturing from
China this pandemic has underscored the
vital importance of reshoring our supply
chains and constructing a powerful
domestic manufacturing base I've been
talking about that for a long time
often times you'd see a plant like this
at a different country doing the work
you could be doing and you'll do it
better the United States declared its
independence nearly 250 years ago but in
recent decades Washington politicians
allowed our independence to be offshored
outsourced and ceded to foreign
countries but we're taking it back and
we've been taking it back and you look
at our job numbers you knew that we were
taking it back so Trump is following up
this announcement with some specific
features of the policy so Reuters is
reporting that the Trump
administration's trying to create an
alliance of trusted partners which will
be called the economic prosperity
Network and this would include companies
and civil society groups operating under
the same set of standards on everything
from digital business energy and
infrastructure to research trade
education and commerce presumably China
will not be a part of this you've got to
ask yourself why we shift everything
over to China in the first place and
there's two reasons there's a kind of
philosophical political reason and then
there's a straight economic reason the
philosophical political reason was that
there was this idea among liberals on
liberals on the left and the right in
the 1990s and in the 2000s that if China
rose up that would be good for the whole
world that would be wonderful
because
China will bring them bet into world
trade will admit them to the World Trade
Organization will get them hooked on
some American culture will you know get
them hooked got hooked on the US dollar
then they'll begin to democratize
because you can't possibly become rich
and not want to follow in the liberal
democratic traditions of the West right
is that how it's gonna work at no turns
out that's not how it worked out at all
actually the richer China got the more
it clamped down on its own population
the more it put millions of its own
citizens in concentration camps the more
relied on slave labor the more it forced
its population to kill its own children
through the one-child policy until
finally they realized they were gonna
have a dying population so they had to
lighten up on that a little bit the more
China started aggressing on the united
states on our interests in the South
China Sea for instance it just didn't
work it just failed it was dumb we
should not have admitted that China to
the World Trade Organization we should
not have cheered them on as they were
rising up because now we're facing the
worst geopolitical adversary we've had
since the Soviet Union so political side
had totally flopped why did we persist
in this so long you know why because we
liked the cheap stuff because we liked
the money because when when you buy
something in America it's more expensive
it's higher quality but it's more
expensive you know sweet little Lisa
said to me the other day won't this
pandemic was starting off she says we've
got to stop buying all this cheap stuff
cheap clothing and stuff from China it's
like it's bad at this point it's
unpatriotic of us to do that we've got
to start buying American clothing I said
well good luck finding it very little
clothing is made intimate very little of
anything is made in America these days
but yes I agree you're right we got to
stop buying stuff from China
we'll start buying stuff from America
and if we got to pay a little bit more
that's fine then I look at how much more
you got to pay you got to pay like
double or more okay but of course you do
of course you do we would not have
upended the world order and allowed this
tyrannical power to rise for just a
little bit of a good deal right no it
was very seductive everything about the
idea of a rising China
very seductive very tempting and we fell
for it now we've got to pull back on
that temptation they're gonna be costs
to that it's gonna cost us more money to
get cheap consumer goods what you're not
gonna be so cheap anymore
it's okay there are bigger questions
here all of politics can't be boiled
down to some stupid scientist in a lab
coat who gets everything wrong and
sleeps with his girlfriend violates his
own orders for instance all of politics
can't be boiled down to just bean
counting and economics that's what the
left wants to do that's not what
conservatism has ever been there's some
things that are worth paying a little
bit more for in anyway there's a no such
thing as a free lunch so president Trump
very big on this manufacturing point as
he's been talking about for a long time
he then tours a Honeywell plan Honeywell
is manufacturing protective personal
equipment and so he tours the plan he's
got his goggles on because you have to
wear the goggles when you're in a
manufacturing plant but notably
he refuses to wear a mask so Zeke Miller
tweets that way on one of the top
journalists in the country tweet said
the president is wearing safety goggles
but no mask on his tour of Honeywell PPE
manufacturing line and if you look at
the responses to Zeke's tweet the
Liberals the left furious at him and the
Conservatives basically appreciative of
this why what's going on here of course
the president can't wear a mass a
facemask
the President of the United States
cannot wear a face mask in public that
projects weakness that looks awkward
politics is about pictures it's about
what we see Trump knows this he's a TV
star you can't wear that you don't I
don't want Vladimir Putin or Kim jong-un
the ghosts of Kim jong-un or anyone else
any other nefarious actor is Xi Jinping
looking at a picture of the American
president so afraid of getting this
virus that he's going to put the mask on
Trump is obviously being tested
constantly so there's no risk of him
transmitting the virus to anybody else
and he's going to accept the risk of
maybe coming into
with the virus in the air or on some
surface or something that's a risk he's
got to take because the images matter
here the projection of us power matters
George W Bush after 9/11 during the
World Series walked into the center of
Yankee Stadium and threw out the first
pitch now obviously he had Kevlar on you
could see it which has made it all the
more amazing that he threw a strike in
the game but obviously it's a huge risk
you've got what 50 60 thousand people in
that stadium maybe not quite that many
but you got a lot of people in that
Stadium packed out stadium anyone could
have taken a shot security at Yankee
Stadium was never that great it was fine
anyone could have taken a shot you're
you're taking a risk to project strength
that's one of your jobs as president and
if George Bush can throw a pitch at at
the World Series then Donald Trump can
walk out in public without a mask on it
reminds me of Reagan and Gorbachev you
know Reagan the first time you met
Mikhail Gorbachev his counterpart in the
Soviet Union this was in 1985 it was in
Geneva I think and Reagan was already at
the house and Gorbachev pulls up and it
was freezing outside right there in
Geneva and Ronald Reagan's an old guy
and he refused to wear a coat and he's
arguably those advisers wear the coat
don't wear the coat Reagan didn't want
to wear the coat he sort of trots down
the stairs to meet Gorbachev Gorbachev
who was younger than Reagan comes out
all bundled up and that image was worth
it was priceless you had this older
American president looking like a young
vigorous man trotting down the stairs
without his coat on and you had this guy
the Soviet leader looking all bundled up
and afraid and and cold and it just that
him he was for Mature was furious about
this because gorbachev knows the power
of symbols well in this case the mask is
a symbol too I'm not saying that if you
come into contact with your grandparents
in your private life that you shouldn't
wear a mask I'm not saying I'm not
saying if you go into a grocery store
you shouldn't wear a mask I'm saying
that the President of the United States
has to think about more than just
protecting his own grandparents who I
suspect they're not alive anymore
the president
States has other things to think about
that's been a big problem in this whole
pandemic is we've only been focusing on
this one narrow aspect the soat the
science of it which a lot of it turned
out to be bunk exalted dr. fowey tells
us how to run our lives you've got to
think about more you've got to think
about the economy you've got to think
about geopolitics you've got to think
about what China's doing the South China
Sea
you've got to think about how Iran is
responding you've got to think about so
much more and you got to think about how
it looks you know a lady in Texas
recognizes the power of images as well
recognizes that there's more to this
whole pandemic than just you know sort
of get getting your material goods
satisfying your own immediate desires
this woman is a salon owner she opened
her salon for a week in defiance of the
lockdown and she was arrested for it in
a judge sentenced her to a week in jail
and a seven thousand dollar fine for
opening her salon business and just you
know trying to trying to feed her kids
so the judge Eric Moy told this owner
Shelly Luthor owner of salon alamode
that he would not make her go to jail if
she just admitted that what she did was
selfish and wrong here's this woman's
answer judge I would like to say that I
have much respect for this court and
laws and that I've never been been in
this position before and it's not
someplace that I want to be but I have
to disagree with you sir when I when you
say that I'm selfish because feeding my
kids is not selfish I have hair stylists
that are going hungry because they'd
rather feed their kids so sir if you
think the law is more important than
kids getting fed then please go ahead
with your decision but I am NOT gonna
shut the salon damn right oh this woman
deserves a prize I want I want President
Trump to give her some kind of metal
I don't know medal of freedom medalist I
love this it's such it's such an obscure
moment right she's in some tiny
court room and Texas nobody's watching
no cameras I mean I guess there are
cameras now because we're in this
lockdown and I guess that's how we got
this footage but she's not on a big
stage she's not on a TV show and yet the
question came down to one of integrity
and that's where questions of integrity
really come when you think nobody's
watching
the judge said yeah this is like out of
George Orwell instead of 1984 yes I'll
go easy on your sentence if you just
admit that feeding your children was
selfish and wrong and you'll always do
exactly what the government tells you to
do even if it's based on bunk science
even if it's an arbitrary power grab you
do what we say say uncle he's basically
twisting her arm behind her back say
uncle say uncle
and she said nah I think I'd rather go
to jail because you can take my week
away from me you can take my money away
from me you can take me away from my
kids but you can't take my integrity you
can make me scream but you can't make me
sing I love it I am so inspired by this
woman we should we should get this video
going all around the judge should be
ashamed of himself those are the kind of
subtle acts of defiance that we need to
start seeing you know already we're
seeing the effect of some of this
pushback the government really clamped
down the government started arresting
pastors because they thought people
ought to be able to go to church well
you know the government clamped down
they gavin newsom in california decided
to specifically close the beaches of his
political opponents he said I'm talking
about Orange County the only
conservative metropolitan county in
California County did not vote for Gavin
Newsom I'm closing your beaches and you
know what people said in Orange County
yeah okay all right Gavin Newsom great I
was one of those people actually was at
the beach on Sunday he's da we're gonna
get you now all of a sudden you say well
maybe we'll start reopening in the next
few weeks
yeah maybe oh thank you daddy Newsom
they're not reopening because they're
not
even talking about reopening out of the
goodness of their heart or because
they're looking at the science what's
what science what science what masques
quarter don't forget the Surgeon General
told us not to wear masks for three
exclamation points it's to stop buying
masks now we've got to buy masks
everything that's not prohibited is
mandatory in this bizarre arbitrary
power grab culture no the reason that
Newsom and other people are loosening up
a little bit is because we're forcing
them to because you can't let drew
Clavin said the other day on his show
you can't lead people where they don't
want to go the good leaders understand
that they've got to take people where
they want to go and they've got to
convince people that they want to go
where they want to go you can't just
force us we're not going to do it okay
if we if we don't go they can't take us
there if we all just go to the beach
they can't shut down the beach and these
subtle acts of defiance I think are very
important and I I fully intend on
embracing them before we go I got to get
to the dumbest article on the internet
actually - well - I'll give you I'll
give it quick just a quick update
there's not really much to say about
this Ruth Bader Ginsberg is in the
hospital how do you think that's being
reported in the mainstream media this
from CNN politics I love this Ruth Bader
Ginsburg resting comfortably after
non-surgical treatment for benign
gallbladder condition they just they
know the minute that the left sees Ruth
Ginsburg in the hospital they say oh no
batten down the hatches the country's
lost no all of our hopes are resting on
this one elderly jurist obviously we
hope we hope worth bitter Ginsburg is
doing just fine one because she's a
human being and we like that but perhaps
more importantly she was friends with
Antonin Scalia so you know you got I got
a wish or well I just love the headline
that all the coverage of whenever
Ginsburg goes to the hospital which is
fairly often is a Ginsburg we're doing
well after a benign non surgery it's all
good nothing to see here don't worry
about it who knows that so this is why
some people joke that we might be living
in a weekend at Ruthie's situation but I
would not joke about that never also
before we go the dumbest article on the
internet comes from the Atlantic as frie
a writer Connor free Duras Dorf
and it it basically gets everything
we've been talking about today exactly
backwards that titleist masks are a tool
not a symbol lives will be lost if
Americans allow the culture war to
determine whether they cover their face
in public
getting masks use exactly right may be
impossible we lack full information
about the efficacy of masks in many
settings and different people have
different value judgments about masks
mandates but here's where he just
obviously negates everything he just
said still the evidence is now quite
robust that masks are effective in at
least some settings is it I don't know
there's a lot of there's been a lot of
robust evidence this whole time that
nobody's been paying attention to
including the people pushing and all
that robust evidence gets reversed
within a week or two if Americans simply
study the evidence and behaved
accordingly erring on the side of
caution many lives could be saved which
makes it frustrating that highly
influential broadcasters who reach
millions of Americans by that he means
conservatives or turning masks into yet
one more front in the culture war
telling their audiences that elites
favor the use of face coverings to take
away the freedom of the masses this is
leftism this is a totally leftist
manifesto at this point if Americans
only studied the evidence they would
realize that we've got to do everything
the leftists tell us to do it's the
evidence it's the science it's not even
forget politics it's just the science
they've just got a look many lives could
be saved no evidence of that at all
there's evidence that the lockdowns are
killing people there's no evidence that
they've saved a single life
it doesn't matter that's the science but
we're not talking about the science
we're talking about the science with a
capital S the narrative that's what they
really mean the leftist narrative and
and you know the Conservatives are just
opening up one more front in the culture
war know you're opening up the culture
war I love this the accused
conservatives of being the aggressors in
the culture war conservatives aren't the
ones who decided that we need to invent
a fictional constitutional right to kill
babies conservatives aren't the ones who
decided to radically redefine marriage
the bedrock institution of society away
from what it has meant everywhere
throughout all of human history
conservatives aren't the ones who
brought drag queens story our into
schools and conservatives aren't the
ones who said that we've got to shut
down the entire global economy throw 30
million people out of work based on
false scientific models not us okay
that's you that did that and forced us
all into these arbitrary cultural
symbolic moments using the phrase using
phrases like social distancing as though
they're now the most important phrase in
our lexicon wearing the masks as though
they're a they're a virtue signaling
badge which they are if people want to
protest can't they wear masks just in
case if only to err on the side of
caution for their neighbors were they to
decide based on the merits of the mask
alone rather than the culture war
premise that issuing masks is a way to
own the libs marginally more would use
face coverings that's if the if the
protesters and the communicators were to
say that it's the culture war premise
and no and no I think the culture war
premise is that governors and
politicians and self-appointed Dictator
scientists can tell us all exactly what
to do without very much evidence
arbitrarily reversing their decisions
day by day and we all just have to go
along with it because you said so
because we serve you
dr. Ferguson or we serve you
Connor Frida's dorth that's a that's a
very radical cultural war premise and I
ain't going with it Fox News and the
Limbaugh program are not niche products
many rely on them as primary source of
information when they turn public health
tools into symbols they hurt the country
and their loyal audiences most of all
the masks are assembled they're also a
tool they can be a tool if you're around
people who are vulnerable if you are a
person who is particularly vulnerable
perhaps you should wear a mask certainly
in certain instances you could wear a
mask okay nobody is suggesting otherwise
for a lot of people this virus is not
particularly dangerous in a lot of
instances the masks don't do anything at
all don't take my word for it listen to
the Surgeon General and all the
scientific experts who told us that for
weeks
in that case the mask is not not a tool
whatsoever it is merely a symbol it is a
it's a it's covering your face
how much more symbolic do you need to
get and what the left is doing I mean
this is exactly what they do with
political correctness this is exactly
what they I mean political correctness
that is the definition of political
correctness is the left forcing us all
to use their symbols
well while pretending that the symbols
aren't symbols right they're forcing us
all to use their words to use their
jargon all of which are symbols while
pretending that it isn't the left
forcing us to believe their political
premises and to advance their political
premises while pretending it's not
political at all it's just science it's
just neutral I don't think so it's very
important that we push back on those
symbols prudence is a virtue we should
use the tools that can help protect us
and other people when that is
appropriate but there are things beyond
matter as well and we've got to pay
attention to those symbolic things
because the ideas the politics the our
loves that our joys and our hopes and
all the things that really matter to us
those are ineffable those are in many
ways represented by symbols and the
symbols we use matters so be more like
that lady in Texas be less like the the
cowards cowering in fear of leftists
yelling at them and the people listening
to hypocrites in the media in the
scientific establishment politics who
won't even follow their own advice and
yet they expect us to follow it
instead all right that's our show I'm
Michael nosiness the Michael Nolt show
see you tomorrow
[Music]
the Michael Knoll show is produced by
Ben Davies and directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy borin
supervising producers Mathis Glover and
Robert Sterling technical producer
Austin Stephens assistant director pavel
madoski
editor and associate producer danny
D'Amico audio mixer robin Fenderson hair
and makeup nikka geneva production
assistant ryan love the michael knowles
show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 20
you know the Matt Walsh oh it's not just
another show about about politics I
think there are enough of those already
out there we talk about culture because
culture drives politics and it drives
everything else so my main focus is our
life family faith those are fundamental
and that's what this show is about I
hope you'll give it a listen
you